what I hope to do in this video is prove
the angle addition formula for sine or
in particular prove that the sine of X
plus y X plus y is equal to is equal to
the sine of X sine of X times the cosine
of sine of I forgot my X sine of X times
the cosine of Y times the cosine of y
plus cosine of X cosine of X times the
sine of Y times the sine of Y and the
way I'm going to do it is with this
diagram right over here that you can
kind of view it as it has this red right
triangle so it has this right triangle
here that has a hypotenuse of one stack
you could say this triangle ADC it has
it stacked on top of its base is the
hypotenuse of triangle ACD which I could
which I could let me outline it in blue
since I already labeled angle the
measure of this angle as being Y so we
have ADC is stacked on or the this AC
which is the base of triangle ADC is is
the hypotenuse of triangle a BC they're
just kind of stacked on top of each
other like that just like that and the
way I'm going to think about it is first
if you just look at this what is sine of
X plus y going to be well X plus y is
this entire angle right over here and if
you look at this right triangle right
triangle a d f we know that the sine of
an angle is the opposite side over the
hypotenuse well the hypotenuse here is 1
so the sine of this is the opposite over
one or the sine of this angle the sine
of X plus y is equal to the length of
this opposite side so sine of X plus y
is going to be equal to the length of
segment DF the length of segment DF and
what I'm going to try to do is say ok
length of segment DF is essentially what
we're looking for but we can decompose
the length of segment DF into two
segments we can decompose
into length of segment de and the length
of segment F so we could say the DF
which is the same thing a sine of X plus
y the length of segment DF is the same
thing is equal to the length of segment
de length of segment de plus the length
of segment EF plus the length of segment
EF and EF is of course the same thing as
the length of segment si be that ECB F
this right over here is a rectangle so
EF is the same thing as CB so this thing
is going to be equal to this thing is
going to be equal to D de right over
here length of segment de plus plus the
length of segment CB plus the length of
segment CB so once again the way I'm
going to address this I'm saying with
the sine of X plus y which is length of
D F and DF can be decomposed as the
lengths of de and CB now with that as a
hint I encourage you to figure out what
the length of segment de is in terms of
X's and Y's and sines and cosines and
also figure out what the length of
segment CB is in terms of X's and Y's
and sines and cosines so try to figure
out as much as you can about this and
and these two just might fall out of
that so I'm assuming you've given a go
at it so now that we we essentially we
know that sine of X plus y can be
expressed this way let's see if we can
figure these things out and I'm going to
try to address it by just figure out as
many lengths as it and in angles here as
I as I can so let's go to this let's go
to this top red triangle right over here
its hypotenuse has length 1 so what's
going to be the length of segment DC
well that is the opposite side of our
angle X so we know sine of X is equal to
DC over 1 or DC over 1 is just DC so
this length right over here is sine of X
and segment AC same exact logic cosine
of X is a is the length of AC over 1
which is just the length of AC
so this length right over here segment
AC is just it's length is cosine is
cosine of X so that's kind of
interesting now let's see what we could
figure out about this triangle triangle
ACB right over here so how could we
figure out CB well we know we know that
sine of Y let me write this here sine of
Y is equal to what it's equal to the
length of segment CB length of segment
CB over the hypotenuse so hypotenuse
here is now cosine of X and I think you
might see where all of this is leading
it at any point if you get excited pause
the video and try to finish the proof on
your own so the length of segment CB if
we just multiply both sides by cosine of
X the length of segment CB is equal to
cosine of X cosine of X times sine of Y
times sine of Y which is neat because we
just showed we just show that this thing
right over here is equal to this thing
right over here so to complete our proof
we just need to prove we just need to
prove that this thing is equal to this
thing right over there if that's equal
to that and that's equal to that well we
already know that the sum of these is
equal to the length of DF which is sine
of X plus y so let's see let's see if we
can figure out if we can express de
somehow now what angle would be useful
well it was somehow we could figure out
this angle up here or maybe maybe this
saying well let's see if we could figure
out this angle if we could figure out
this angle then then de we could express
in terms of this angle and sine of X
let's see if we can figure out that
angle so we know we know this is angle Y
over here and we also know we also know
that this is a right angle so EC is
parallel to a B so you could view AC is
a transversal so if this is angle Y
right over here then we know this is
also angle Y these are once again
and we'll notice this is if AC is a
transversal here in EC and a be a
parallel then if this is Y then that is
Y then if that's Y then this is 90 minus
y 90 minus y and if this is 90 degrees
and this is 90 minus y then these two
angles combined add up to 180 minus y
and so if all three of these out of 180
then this thing up here must be equal to
Y validate that y plus 90 minus y plus
90 is 180 degrees and that is useful for
us because now we can express segment de
in terms of Y and sine of X we what is
de - y is the adjacent angle so we could
think of cosine we know we know that the
cosine of angle Y if we look at triangle
Dec right over here we know that the
cosine of Y is equal to segment de is
equal to segment de over its hypotenuse
over sine of X and you should be getting
excited right about now because we've
just shown we've just shown if we
multiply both sides by sine of X we've
just shown that de is equal to sine of X
sine of X times cosine of Y cosine of Y
so we've shown we've now shown this this
is equal to this we already showed that
CB is equal to that so the sum of de and
CB which is the same thing as the sum of
de and EF is the sine of X plus y which
is that over there so we are done we
have proven the angle addition formula
for sine